I do not pretend to be a medical
professional I do not pretend to be a
neurologist or a mental health
specialist but fortunately none of those
things are requirements to notice that
there is something very wrong with the
President of the United States and
there's a new report that says Donald
Trump is regularly stumbling slurring
and confused at the White House now I'll
be totally upfront this could be drug
abuse as we've covered this could be
early stage dementia this could be some
other form of cognitive decline this
could be the side effect of some
medication we've not been told Donald
Trump is on he's not been particularly
forthcoming about his health
circumstances this could be any number
of things but it's something that is
what is very clear and it keeps coming
up every time we hear from another White
House insider there's a new book called
a warning it's from the same anonymous
staff member who wrote that New York
Times op-ed last year we have some
viewers who are speculating about who it
might be might be we'll talk about that
in the voicemail segment today they
claim to be part of the resistance
inside the Trump administration and as
usual if merely 5% of what's alleged in
the book is true it's cause for
immediate alarm concern and action here
is a quote from the book / The
Washington Post I am not qualified to
diagnose the president's mental acuity
all I can tell you is that normal people
who spend any time with Donald Trump are
uncomfortable by what they witness he
stumbles slurs gets confused is easily
irritated and has trouble synthesizing
information not occasionally but with
regularity those who would claim
otherwise are lying to themselves or to
the country now there's a bunch of other
stuff in the book about Trump making fun
of women's physical appearance making
fun of people's weight Trump is you know
likely technically obese by the way he
still makes fun of other people's weight
the regular stunned nature of the people
around him but that stuff isn't even
really news or it pales and importance
really compared to this this is yet
another data point it's another set of
allegations
- what is in plain sight yet somehow
it's considered to be in poor taste to
talk about this inappropriate to talk
about this this is the presidency this
should go beyond party unable to put
together coherent sentences being very
up in one speech with dilated pupils and
hours later being down like he's coming
down from uppers and slurring and it's
almost like he can't get his tongue out
of the way to speak wanting to get to
the oranges of an investigation
repeating that twice but looking
confused as if he recognizes that what's
coming out of his own mouth doesn't make
sense but seemingly unable to make any
sense walking out of Air Force One
facing his limousine but starting to
wander away until a staffer can take him
by the arm and bring him back to the car
something similar happened when he was
greeting the Argentinean president at
the g7 I believe it was in Argentina and
on and on and on so I implore you put
politics aside for a moment this is an
unfit person to be president merely on
the basis of his cognitive state alone
now let me propose something that is now
floating around there is a point of view
that this is all staged and concocted
the idea is create a pretext for a
Reagan defense for Donald Trump if and
when criminal charges are brought
against him for who knows which list of
the litany of criminal acts that he
likely has committed as president you
know the thing about that that makes me
doubt it and I'm curious to see what you
think is that I don't believe Trump
thinks that that's going to happen and I
don't know that Trump is really putting
people around him in decision-making
situations who believe that that is
going to happen I just don't think Trump
has any idea what he's doing period the
motive is certainly there you might at
some point face criminal problems
because of your presidency let's start
to create a pretext that you're not
cognitively with it I just don't think
they believe Trump is ever really going
to face consequences for what he's done
and that's what makes me think the idea
that this is staged is unlikely to be
the right one
I believe what we are seeing is just
reality Donald Trump is barely being
held together by a thread and we've
actually got a specific example from
this weekend that I want to talk about
next